So let's talk about how we determine
what the block offset is and
what the block number
is given an address.
Let's say that the processor
produces a 32 bit address,
with bits numbered from 0 through 31.
So this is the address of the location
the processor wants us
to find in the cache.
The cache can be seen as an array
of lines each block size in size.
In this example,
let's look at 16 as the block size.
Some bits of this address tell us
which block are we talking about and
some bits are telling us where in
the block are we looking for our data?
With a block size of 16
we need to determine
how many bits tell us
where in the block we are.
The block has 16 bytes,
2 to the 4th is 16,
so we need 4 bits to tell us
where within a block we are.
That means that bits zero through three,
are going to tell us,
once we find the block in the cache,
which part of the block to read.
The remaining bits, bits 4 through 31,
tell us which block
are we trying to find.
So these bits that tell us where in
the block are we going to find our data,
are called the block offset.
And the bits that tell us which
block are we interested in
are called the block number.
So what we do is we access
the cache trying to find the block
according to the block number.
If we find the block, we use the block
offset to get the right data
from the block because there is more
than one location in the block.